let's now think a little bit more about
how we might model population growth and
as we do so we're going to become a
little bit more familiar with the types
of formulas that you might see in ap
biology formula sheet so in a previous
video we introduced the idea of per
capita growth rate of a population and
we used the letter r for that and so
let's say that the per capita growth
rate for a population is 0.2
that means that on average for every one
individual in that population a year
later it would have grown by twenty
percent by two tenths so for every one
you would now have one point two of that
population a year later now as we
mentioned many populations that are the
ones that reproduce sexually you need at
least two a male and a female but there
are populations of certain things that
can just reproduce on their own they can
just bud or they can divide if we're
talking about especially unicellular
organisms
and from this notion we can get a
related notion which is our maximum per
capita growth rate of a population and
let me just write that there you could
view this as your per capita growth rate
if the population is not limited in any
way if there's ample resources water
food land territory whatever that
population needs to grow but that still
is talking about per capita growth rate
of population we're just viewing is this
is the unfettered one this is the
maximum
and from that we can set up an
exponential growth equation and we've
seen this in other videos where the rate
of change of our population with respect
to time n is our population so dn dt is
our rate of change of population with
respect to time or our population growth
rate right over here let me write this
down population
growth
rate
if we're dealing with a population that
in no way is being limited by its
ecosystem which in reality is not
realistic at some point you would be
well then the rate of great the rate of
growth of population is going to be your
maximum per capita growth rate of
population
times your population itself
and we could see set up a little table
here to see how these would relate to
each other so let me do that
let me set up a
table
and so let's think about what the rate
of change of population will be our
population growth rate for certain
populations so let's think about what
it's going to be when our population is
100 when our population is 500 and when
our population is
900.
so given these populations what would be
your population growth rate for each of
them pause this video and try to answer
that
well when our population is 100 our
population growth rate is just going to
be 0.2 times that so 0.2 let me write
this down this is just going to be dndt
is just going to be 0.2 our maximum per
capita growth rate of population times
our population times 100 which is equal
to 20.
so we're going to grow per year by 20
when our population is a hundred now
what about when our population is 500
what is going to be our population
growth rate pause the video again and
try to answer that
well once again we just take our maximum
per capita growth rate and multiply it
times our population so 0.2 times 500
our population growth rate is now 100.
if we're talking about bunnies this
would be and if our time is in years
this would be 100 bunnies per year or
100 individuals per year and let's think
about it when our population is 900
what's our population growth rate then
pause the video again
all right well we're going to take 0.2
times 900 so it is going to be 180
individuals per year
now as i just mentioned this is talking
about a somewhat unrealistic situation
where a population can just grow and
grow and grow and never be limited in
any way we know that
land is limited food is limited water is
limited and so there there's this notion
of a natural carrying capacity
of a given population in a given
environment and to describe that we'll
use the letter k
and so let's say we for the organisms
that we're studying here let's say
they're bunnies and in their bunnies on
a relatively small island let's say that
the natural carrying capacity for that
island is one thousand that the island
really can't support more than one
thousand bunnies
so how would we change this exponential
growth equation right over here
exponential
to reflect that
well what mathematicians and biologists
have done is they've modified this they
multiply this times a factor to get us
what's known as logistic growth
logistic
growth
so this is exponential growth
and what we're going to now talk about
is logistic growth and what they do is
they start with the exponential growth
so my population growth rate
you could view as
your maximum per capita growth rate
times your population so that's exactly
what we had right over here but then
they multiply that by a factor so that
this thing slows down the closer and
closer we get to the carrying capacity
and the factor that they add is you're
carrying capacity
minus
your population
over
over your carrying capacity
now let's see if this makes intuitive
sense so let's set up another table here
and i'll do it with the same values
so let's say
we have
n so our population what's going to be
our population growth when our
population's 100 when it's 500 and when
it's 900 so i encourage you pause this
video and figure out what dn dt is at
these various times
well at 100 it's going to be i'll do
this one i'll write it out it's going to
be 0.2
times
our the carrying capacity is 1000 so
it's going to be 1 000
minus 100 all of that over
so this is 900 over a thousand this is
going to be 0.9 and then 0.2 times 100
is 20. so 20 times 0.9 this is going to
be equal to
18. so it's a little bit lower it's
being slowed down a little bit but it's
pretty close now let's see what happens
when we get to n equals 500 pause this
video and figure out what dn dt our
population growth rate would be at that
time
so in this case it's going to be 0.2
times 500
times 500 times this factor here which
is now going to be 1000
minus
500 that's our population now
minus 500 all of that over
1 000. now what's this going to be this
is 100 which we had there but it's going
to be multiplied by 500 over 1000 which
is 0.5 so we're only going to grow half
as fast as we were in this situation
because once again we don't have an
infinite amount of resources here so
this is going to be
100 times 0.5 which is equal to 50.
and then if you look at this scenario
over here when our population is 900
what is dndt pause the video again
well it is going to be 0.2
times 900 which is 180 times this factor
which is going to be
minus
all of that
over 1000
so now this factor is going to be
100 over a thousand which is 0.1 0.1
this part right over here is
this part right over here is 180 180
times 1 10 is going to be equal to 18.
so now our population growth has slowed
down why is that happening here your
population rate the rate of growth is
growing and growing and growing because
the more bunnies or whatever types of
individuals you have there's just more
to reproduce and they're just going to
keep growing exponentially but here
they're getting closer and closer to the
carrying capacity of whatever
environment they're at and so at 900
they're awfully close so now you're
going to have some bunnies that are
going hungry and maybe they're not in
the mood to reproduce as much or maybe
they're getting killed or they're
they're dying of this is very unpleasant
thinking they're they're dying of
starvation or they're not able to get
water dehydration who knows what might
be happening and we could also think
about this visually
if we were to make
a quick graph right over here where if
this is time
and if this is population our
exponential growth right here would
describe something that looks like this
so for exponential growth our population
will grow like this the more our
population is the faster it grows the
more it is the faster it grows the more
it is it faster grows it'll just keep
going forever until it just you know
there's no limit in theory and obviously
we know that's not realistic now with
logistic growth i'll do this in red and
logistic growth in the beginning it
looks a lot like exponential growth it's
just a little bit slower
but then as the population gets higher
and higher it gets a good bit slower and
it's limited by the natural carrying
capacity of the environment for that
population so k
would be right over there it would
asymptote up to it but not quite
approach it and if you want to think at
the limit what would happen well what
happens at a population of a thousand in
this circumstance well then this factor
right over here just becomes zero so
your population at that point just
wouldn't grow anymore if you were to
even get there